hey folks Daniel Dwyer here here with a
developer we don't usually have
developers here on the now playing couch
Tom Francis but since you're in town we
thought we'd invite you in thank you
very much for joining us today
for those who don't know you're the
gentleman who used to write about video
games we then made his own gunpoint your
turns out that game was pretty okay you
worked on that sort of on your weekends
for yeah a couple of years right
strictly weekend so it'd be three years
but that was because I was just working
weekends I didn't want to burn out I
don't work in the evenings or anything
yeah I still get my day job and then I
didn't risk it all and to chase a
beautiful dream I just like refused to
take any risks whatsoever yeah very very
slowly gradually built this thing and
only after it came out and only after it
was definitely successful enough like it
quit my job without making any kind of
risk did I actually do that that's good
that's right like we were talking about
the british-american thing it's very
British way of doing it it's making
exactly sure that it all works extremely
cautious and terrified but you're taking
maybe a little bit of risk now because
you've been working on at your latest
game and your signature for a couple
years as well yeah coming from two years
now yeah waiting to make all right let's
jump straight in I've been dying to
check it out I've seen up what's your
YouTube videos you very good like books
or showing off your development process
but yeah let's live into the game itself
what is he to injure it is a top-down
space stealth game in a randomly
generated open-world and so you're in
the stang little ship that has no
weapons and you're flying around a huge
galaxy like we have Sam while we've been
talking we've drifted off almost into
nothingness that's okay because I'm
gonna actually regenerate the galaxy
okay this doesn't crush the game that's
right yes this is a very early build
correct it is extremely hot off the
presses I made this build about 40
minutes ago I played it maybe twice
grace so if anything goes wrong the
beauty of of solo development is where
are you working in this on your own did
anyone else happen graphics yes the art
is done by John Roberts also did they
offer gunpoint chuckle and the music is
by John Halpert
hmm so this basic when you start the
game it generates a gang
- plane and the galaxy is kind of like
your playthrough you're gonna stay in
that for the rest of the game okay and
if you started a new one it would be
because you know it would be like
starting a new RPG kappa present yeah
and I'm gonna regenerate a couple more
times so if we get a nice one
oh wow so this gives you an idea of like
how different they can be and are they
very far away from each other or can you
fast travel to each one oh they these
are so this is like the whole game world
you're sitting right now right and when
I regenerator I'm just wiping the game
world actually they're like the code
critter says destroy the galaxy generate
the galaxy so this is an open house on
all those kind of spotty so it's a very
random right now this is yeah like the
way I start everything is first make it
truly random and then if that goes wrong
then refine loads it
I like it's like pillars of eternity
kind of thing happening here yeah I'm
just gonna turn the tips off for a
second because I know what they say
that's why we have you here this is
that's you and all of these white dots
are space stations and all the lines
between them and trade routes okay and
the idea is that you work for one of
these factions so she didn't notice what
faction were in was it sugar and I found
three so we work with a foundry they're
a faction that built this whole place
and Space Station's very placeholder at
the moment they will be carved out of
asteroids oh wow and the idea is this is
a kind of pocket of space that the
foundry was sent to investigate and see
if it had any potential for a mining
colony they had all the equipment with
them to build one and it did but it also
bricked their FTL ships and they
stranded there okay they built a whole
kind of society here and then since then
the people who sent them here have been
wondering like hey where do those guys
get to it is there any money in it and
so they shown up now to kind of muscle
in on my territory and a bunch of other
factions are all there for their own
reasons some of them selfish some of
them just survive and some kind of
altruistic maybe mmm-hmm so the idea is
when you start the game you pick a
character and their work for a
particular faction we're working found
you right now and then when you go to a
space station you take a mission and it
zooms you out to
the galaxy map and gives you a bunch of
options for emotions so these each one
of these will be something aboard a ship
the guy they need to steal or kill in
some case you have to hijack the ship so
one like it say for instance I've played
a lot of lead dangerous over the past
year unlike that you were not just
shipping things from base to base
necessarily you're actually going inside
of the other ships and yeah this is you
whoever you play as whichever faction
you work for you are a kind of space
commando II job it is to I think the
term I'm using is breacher and that's
someone who flies out to other space
ships and goes inside them and does kind
of precise spotty type work involving
killing people stealing things so it's
gonna point in space to be nice and
reductive about your past to work the
two years of work so you'll see you and
actually bought something but for now
all i care about is which one of these
trade routes done' break right so each
one of those are pointing to a different
raid route and when you do it the idea
is you're intercepting is really
valuable piece of cargo or person and
when you steal or kill that thing the
alien faction will abandon that trade
route because too dangerous all right
okay so in that way you can kind of
isolate the enemy stations so just gonna
grab a crown take an assassination cool
and run back to my ship I've just got
wrenches wound up in here I'm gonna have
it so that the various characters you
can you players will have some kind of
starting equipment but it's a little bit
different so if you're specializing
assassinations you might start with a
silenced pistol
if you're a bounty on team I have a
non-lethal weapon is there any other RPG
style elements to come in specifically
with your character or you have a lot of
most of your abilities based on just
your equipment and so that's stuff you
find for active play through but it's
permadeath at the galaxy is persistent
okay when I do this mission which I'll
definitely succeed at and let's go up
it's gonna break this trade route and
that trade will be broken forever for
everyone
oh wow so sorry not for like other
players but I mean for all your future
lives every time you start the game
you're playing as a new person in this
galaxy the Galaxy itself will bear all
the scars and and marks of your missions
so you carry over any of the resources
at all or can you go get those or are
you very much starting all over so your
character loses less stuff and we kind
skip time for words a week so the idea
is that like scavengers would have taken
all your ships and you can't just I
didn't want to incentivize you to just
spend the start of every life finding
the culture the last character on to go
because that doesn't make any sense
probably in a completely different
direction maybe so anyway this is the
ship with the assassination target
aboard and if I can get close enough to
the airlock then I can dock with it so
it didn't see you because the scanners
were at the front was that right yeah so
it's got a vision cone there it doesn't
have any heat sensors which is the wrong
type of of ways that it can detect you
there's your body I think we just passed
a station show over here yeah this is a
target oh [ __ ] you're gonna fire you're
just screwed up the easiest mission oh
he hasn't killed me just hit me in the
head with a wrench and tell you out I'm
not quite unconscious I'm just about
able to use remote control for my ship
and he's kicked me out of the airlock
and like hi I'm remote controlling my
ship to come and pick myself up so
that's me
and if I can actually manage to catch
myself I'm okay so focus your eyes great
there was a bar at the bottom screen
there showing how much blood I'd have
left run out of blood you pass out and
you no longer save yourself he's gonna
be so pissed he didn't finish you off so
yeah so he can be very surprised when
you walk back in do it slowly let it be
loans but the idea is like this type of
information you're doing is just kind of
relatively new you know this is a ship
that can avoid all the standard few
senses try to be stealthy is incredibly
fast it can get past all the locks on
any airlock and so the fact that you're
boarding a ship at all is kind of a bit
of a shock to them and when you're
aboard
so my excuse there is that I just
changed the controls like half an hour
ago
so they're better for new players but
not so good for someone who's really
used to playing the old version so sure
it I'm going to use slow-mo
and that's currently is unlimited so now
we're in slow motion and doing that I'm
about to throw my wrench at this guy oh
wow I got a very thick skulls I can
recover from that I almost never seem to
a urinal which I think'll so I had a
wrench of just taking this guy's gun but
there are risks associated using a gun
because I don't if you can see it but
there's a big white circle around me
they're all around here yes how long who
will hear it if I fire okay so all these
guys in turret seats there will all hear
it if I use it now so I think I'm gonna
rush out and just smack this guy I'll
take a wrench for good measure in case I
want to throw it later
what are you going to base the slow-mo
on and the final version is it going to
be I thought about having it be like I
sort of adrenaline like tablet that you
take but actually I'm really liking it's
being unlimited so maybe it'll just be
kind of like a recharge thing mmm the
risk is if you make something a
consumable item then certain kind of
player including me will just call them
forever
yeah ISM and slow is awesome they should
be using all the time so it does make
game pretty easy so probably should be
limited to some extent but also it's
really good for new players because if
you don't know how combat works it's
extremely volatile you know you fire a
gun
almost every fires a gun dies like the
first time they play so a safety net
okay I'm gonna shoot this guy because
he's my assassination target
amazing he's like I thought I got rid of
last time oh my god this guy's - okay
we're gonna fast forward we're gonna get
back really fast every time you get hit
like that you lose a bit of blood
permanent cool
so your timer is tighter next time but
luckily I'm fairly experienced at doing
this now I've died a lot in this game
try to avoid that [ __ ] honestly I think
I know it was like you know
unintentional that's call it a merchant
or something like the idea of rushing
after your body which is spaceship so is
tremendous first boarded I was going to
knock this guy on head of the wrench
yeah when I when he hurt me once I came
back and was gonna shoot him now I think
I gotta blow him up if I can get him
into a room with a fuel barrel then
we'll be set so what was the inspiration
for this then because obviously the you
know the the lazy journalists for me
would would pull in games like FTL and
hotline Miami instant yeah I am totally
fine with those comparisons FDI was
definitely a conscious inspiration oh my
god there's not a guy at the scene sir
okay so this guy's coming now
and I'm sure captain forever had a big
influence oh yes
chips are made out of these squares and
I didn't consciously you sort of take
that from I'm captain Grover but here we
go he's going to the feel better one
it's perfect okay yes oh my god but just
like the last time so I'm fine I'm not
bleeding he didn't hit me or anything
okay I just got sucked out of space
which is that's just business as usual
for you as a space commander and now I
can pick myself up and that going it's
finally finally dead
that's axial I wasn't expecting the the
the ship to decompress like that yeah so
that happens anytime there's explosion
it destroys the whole room that it
happens in and that rips people out
through vacuum you can also like split a
ship in half if you don't plant
explosives so this thing here that was
the trade route that was going along it
actually went way past its destination
because there's no like where your point
system yet but we've broken it now why
and if we break that trade route as well
this station will be isolated right and
then we can capture it hopefully so I'm
gonna go back to my foundry station you
can fast forward any time just like you
can slow-mo just as well why the end a
space game that's probably yeah there's
there's arguments against like proper
fast travel where your teleport I think
you don't want to do that but I also
don't need to be bored on long journey
so yeah just let's get all that must be
difficult for like a game set in space
as a developer to try and make a game
that sort of has the vastness of space
and gives you that feeling of distance
but without you know forcing people to
be bored yeah I found actually so you
zoom really fast this game yeah that
kind of actually takes away some of the
sense of scale so I'm kind of playing
around with ways that we kind of
smoothly adjust the zooms you're flying
around like the faster you're going the
more we pull out and the slower pulls
out the better it feels basically mmm
that sounded wrong you heard it here
first kids slowly black it better feels
so I'm actually at a shop now so I just
got some money for that mission and I
can buy any of these weapons you can see
you let straight to the weapon down the
side and
these the ones I picked up all the ones
I stole actually just standard pistols
do came from like generic guards mm-hmm
and now they've got some cash I can't
afford this one
that one's got loads of projectiles this
one's slightly silent it's like shotguns
pretty good and I kind of would but this
one's quiet and I can't afford it and
that one is quiet and rapid-fire so we
would go for that one so that means
you're the cone of influence this is the
only one I can buy there's no so yeah
you can probably see the circle now oh
yeah playing background that's the kind
of noise radius will also you make that
bit Keira and then let's go mission to
break that other trade ring cool or oh
wait hang on I would commercially
capture that station it's already Isis
yeah it was already I think and
hopefully that no but we can take out
okay let's take out this one that will
break that will make one nice link so
the one that is already isolated reminds
I'll just grab that so I'll just click
that to make that trade route so what's
the end goal if there is one is this
just an emergent like world where you
can just actually it's pretty sandbox
see right now you can work for any
faction that's all every character play
is basically the same the plan is that
they would each character choose already
works a fraction and it'll just work for
them and you have to expand their
territory a certain amount and I'm
thinking that when the game starts will
probably let you will ask you to pick a
faction and then you are working for
them until you expand their territory
enough that they are kind of like stable
so that factions trouble we work for
them until we're not in trouble
and then you unlock the ability players
like this other faction yeah one of the
new characters you can play as is works
for the enemy and he players them and
you kind of see their perspective
there's not a lot of stories stuff
because it's all randomly generated but
you will see on this screen where you're
picking missions it says against chigi
you'll find out what found bear you
think of chica chica is the company that
sent foundry here and then came just
kind of take this place back once they
found out that it was full of these
incredibly precious like gases and
minerals and stuff and from foundries
perspective she portrayed them from
Gigi's perspective family betrayed them
and they disagree about like the
fundamental facts of what happened and
so you're kind of your Ark of
understanding the backstory of this
place will be strongly influenced by
what pattern you pick in the first place
what faction unlocks an ex
and that kind of process of seeing the
other side of each little kind of
conflict will keep going and be kind of
different or every player so which one's
going to do this one I'd also accept a
mission to fire your gun array just
blast off I like it so presumably the
the space stations themselves are more
difficult to take over then the are they
well so right now we just take it over
automatically once it's activated you
can just click a button and it makes
that trade route I would like you to
actually sneak inside the space station
and you know as you saw a specialist in
to improve ro moments there's no point
in doing a mission for that just yet but
yeah like the idea is that once you're
isolated them you capture them that's
how you expand your territory that's how
you progress and this ship Scott similar
thing it's got only a couple of sensors
at the front or it does yeah all right
this one I've got a high jacket so I'm
gonna sneak in and switch to wrench cuz
that as quite as that gun is it's not
quite enough that I'm totally sure we're
waking you up
because they turret Gunners can't skin
you can arrange it
oh man that wrench made a little bit of
noise I think she kind of just like
glimpse me they went round the corner
all right so it is like as you can tell
it's quite a game of sudden-death games
even the guy who made it can't actually
play confidence there's a twitchiness to
it all for sure yeah so but it's also
forgiving right I haven't actually died
yet I've just been injured and jacked
into space and so I wanted to be kind of
like a cookie being rogue like one where
you can always see your death coming and
you always have a way to avoid it
and so bleeding out that's the death
that you can see coming suddenly getting
shot from round a caught up with a
backhander it's fine it's fine as fine
what I'm trying to do which is maybe
we've ambitious would sneak to the
cockpit before I take it one out and
then zoom out and then I can set
autopilot to my destination oh really
I can't quite pick out because this
mouse is not what I'm used to yeah it's
a so now this ship is going to fly there
automatically and I don't need to be in
it's and I can take my time figuring out
the rest now that's gay nobody there
like that we just turned they just kind
of felt dumb man yeah I just they
assumed the commander knows what he's
doing
like that's not my paygrade theory if
you're going a slow mo you should be
able to catch your wrench because you're
already into actually like hit the front
flow try it yeah okay this is ultra
slow-mo it comes towards me okay it
wasn't going fast enough
yes nice the things the things you do to
pass time in space yeah yeah what was
just sort of main impetus for going down
this road because it is you know
especially if somebody who's made their
first game you'd expect the follow-up to
be relatively similar like we talked
about hotline Miami hotline Miami 2 was
very much in the vein of the first game
so why something why did the fundamental
shift in perspective from sidon to
top-down and white space instead of
spies
I always it's true so cool
I'm always keen to do so I knew the idea
of doing gunpoint to is not really
appealing to me when I'm done with
gunpoint I was really dumb company my
work they've been you know consuming all
my weekends for three years
yeah and so luckily I did well enough
that I you know had the freedom to take
on something a bit riskier and just
experiment with stuff I tried two
different prototypes that tried one that
was a more like gunpoint and had a
grappling hook in it and that was going
pretty well but it was just harder going
and I had this idea halfway through and
happy thing but like after a couple
months of experimentation and this idea
I already knew how to make it in game
maker yeah I could see that it was
doable and it just seemed more exciting
just seemed like it had war it was more
novel I just haven't seen anything quite
like this before so yeah that's mainly
why so we've missed our destination
slightly that's okay I can board back on
and I think did I clear out the whole
place in the end it seems pretty safe
you've definitely at an eye for them in
spotting them and I haven't been
spotting them quite yet
so actually what we should do is
let's mark it to the right place we'll
turn around and while it's traveling
actually once it's delivered I think I'm
gonna blow it up because it doesn't like
we're in the final game you'll be
delivering a station or kind of go into
some kind of port in every nice
animation flap got that working yet
and you'll fire your gun because you
completed the mission yeah got a second
celebration
maybe I gotta fly it in man you action
it's really having trouble the automatic
oh [ __ ] it's a really fast ship that's
why so when you steer it manually it
kind of has a bit of swing to it yeah
and if I start walking around there no
the whole universe is spinning around
come on no this likes of Sandra Bullock
[ __ ] I can't do it where are you based
close to London you and Bathory
yeah you've just down the road from your
fellow space massive space sim
developers hello games yeah I guess so
no too far there in Guildford right yeah
have you ever talked to Sean Murray and
those folks about there no efforts
trying to make these types of games
you've both taken on rather large scale
project it's hard not to sort of see
your game of suffering slightly in
comparison to an Omaha guys yeah like I
get invited on to bloody this game was
never really about scale or anything but
any game now where you zoom out and show
right a big galaxy inevitably gets
compared to that this is much more about
for me it's about like the sort of nitty
gritty mechanics of boarding a ship and
all the sneaky things you can do and the
scale of the galaxy is kind of like a
just context yes sir
here's why you're doing it you're gonna
break this trade route you can expand
your factions territory you don't have
to care about that stuff at all and
hopefully the actual game of routing a
spaceship will be fun enough that yeah I
like the idea of exploring the various
different it's like you know figuring
out then you when you get explosives
like how that blends into all the rules
you already know about this game like
how you can use that stuff to your
advantage and stuff so I'm gonna place a
that's now that's a like a c4 start
explosive enough place one there and one
maybe over here so that will dial blow
up those right now fuel canisters as
well maybe yeah it's gonna hopefully rip
in half hit one I've cheated so I gave
myself so much inventory there's
actually a lot to scroll through at all
make sure you're on the right side of
that bouquet yeah fantastic so
presumably if you were trying to attack
somebody who is in one side of the ship
or like a little partition somebody's
like on yeah like a yeah little wing of
the ship you just blow it off before you
kill them one of the next things I
planned is guards who are sort of heavy
armored and they're immune to your
bullets it means you're wrenches and
stuff and so if you want to get rid of
one of those guys you got a second into
space or actually blow him up in the
blast so join up here yeah sure okay
yeah I'll have a garbage pull it over
so yeah apologies to everyone if this
starts looking real gnarly all of a
sudden that's because luckily I've set a
really low bar fish great and killed
this like three times that's the same
mission that's true all right so I'm
guessing I'm left clicking
yep left first it's controlling as you
would imagine if you were attempting to
do this yeah and you can right click to
slow down okay that's what that is
and also if you're flying up to a ship
right click or match your speed to it
while you hold it down I should go to
this guy here yeah so we actually
succeed in that mission so there is a
like an isolated station down there so
you might want to go kind of
and it's one airing yeah that's the one
you got to capture so actually the one
you heading to is perfect this guy oh
yeah because you better make the new
trade route from there who would like
glow when I go faster
it's your heat so the more you thrust
the hotter you get and that when you
kind of shape with heat senses that
makes it harder to approach them because
they you have to wait for your heat to
cool off before you can kind of get past
the sensor and dock we haven't found all
those yet because it's a randomized game
so things go differently so I gotta go
off to this guy here oh yeah stations
should be solid they're not right now
like I say they're gonna be carved out
of massive asteroid so it's the
asteroids part that would be thanks that
was easier to docked in my first time in
Toledo yeah all right so here are the
formations currently yes you should
that station capture one that I will
create the trade route to to their
coolant that's just kind of a free thing
just agree should I do that or do
something do it you'll still be able to
take a mission after you look so perfect
I know it's just oh yeah Donna and
Dustin are already there I think the way
that might work is like you click it and
then a ship actually leaves the station
I'll go on and kind of forges the trade
route as it goes yeah all right so go
cargo here hijack except I think I like
the what's the theft so we haven't done
one of those yeah so that's just
stealing like a kind of bit of prototype
technology okay and right now it I think
it might just upgrade your ship a bit
but the longer-term plan is that the
actual kind of pull loop that you'll be
finding aboard ships and buying from
shops will be quite limited at first and
your theft missions will be to steal
component parts to kind of invent new
stuff right and in that way if you
invent the concussion grenade then
that's available for all your future
characters as well I'll call it within
the universe yeah so it's another level
of persistence that we can do well I I
see it it pays out the most which
probably means is the hardest when I
give it a go right now the economy of
the game was added yesterday right the
pay of a mission is actually completely
random
let's see let's see if I can pull this
one off I think you just wanted a debt
back oh yeah oh we did because it's the
last pot in high price yeah you know
what I'm just gonna walk out I don't
know what happens if you destroy a
mission computer on our station because
things ever tried that before David
let's see if it's still there when we
come back here and then we'll see if
that if that's doable I'll stuff I how
do you feel what's the fuss middle
buildin me look like and then F if
you're on a fast forward oh yeah
so they you kind of hold it down if you
like keep going and the autopilot spends
half your journey accelerating and half
of it decelerating oh great
so there's no actual upper speed limit
it's just a question of good fuel
efficiency yeah and the kind of upgrades
that you're about to steal currently
give you better thrusters and better
cooling systems did you say left-click
matches the speed right trip all right
and then that makes it easy to dock that
was a thing we added because most people
like everyone struggles a little bit
with docking the first time they do it
yeah I'm happy because it's a difficult
thing but we also found that like just
about 10% or 5% of people just never got
it or easily just if that thing's moving
and they're moving it's just a
prescription ever
I could never they can never take into
account their own velocity so super fast
this way and they need to go left they
just dusted left which of course goes
diagonally and then there whatever
direction that's funny just some people
just can yeah I had to watch them kind
of struggle with it again and again and
again and finally realized what they
need is something that matches their
speed yeah to their destination and then
from there they can go so we just don't
pass the space station yep had always
change weapon number keys or brush cute
it's like three things she did so you've
got so much stuff that you've got thanks
Tom that's perfect alright so where's my
where's my bit of kid I need to get over
there and there and it's behind a locked
door so you're gonna have to use that
orange computer to open it but I would
advise hearing out the area a bit first
oh so if i unlock the door well they
probably get wise to it not so much that
but just while you're sitting in that
seat they like quite possible for them
to come down a corridor it's all about
like your attention is your most limited
resource here it's very hard to keep an
eye on them and do something else at the
same time kill them there's all these
doors have padlocks on them are
different lock levels and that's level
one I think the one for your objective
is level two and which is from the
central computer you have a certain
number like a hat points mm hacks you
can get away with basically and those
will be used up when you bypass those
doors but you can also find key cards
and if you find a level one key card
that is fat fat then you will be able to
open all level one doors on a little
their ships so it's kind of like getting
better us to pack it away with that one
the guys are the wrench is a set of if
you know they're coming it's been pretty
easy just kind of swipe your wrench
madly you can throw it at them which has
got like a finance move but it
frequently bounces back in the other
face as we've seen the elegant thing to
do is throw it at them when it bounces
back kind of slide set and of course the
ultra all I can think is just slide step
and catch it is okay so yeah if you hold
down shift you can scroll the view
around and I move the mouse well shift
ourselves like I yes it's kinda like
panning of you
so yeah just click on that door why
pause it oh nice okay so I guess I
should maybe open while I'm here no I
think if you're sitting them that you're
sitting in those seats is I feel like I
would just yeah it's like when I don't
you know dove into the matrix or
something I'm just sitting there like oh
yeah and if you look at the guys who are
sitting in seats you'll see we have like
a sort of VR helmet thing on so they are
totally immerse and they can't see you
at all like I had a custom pistol lately
so you don't take that yeah
you know what use it though yeah we
can't actually see what's properties
oxic a few seventy [ __ ] items Oh
so left is that slow down yeah so right
master so down to a crawl space
and didn't even knock yourself out
hey sweet already completed can i mess
about in here then yeah I gonna try and
blow some so there was actually I talked
you out of opening any other doors but
the compressor in fact he had a cockpit
sealed off so this is like a ship that
would be slightly hard at the hijacked
if you say if you didn't have easy
access to the door controls well it's
shift what's it like that shower room
it's a like kind of freezer for food and
stuff I think everything the placement
of those again I start with the total
randomness and then we kind of tweak
from there so right now that can create
just a bathroom in the middle of a
massive hallway or urinals like we said
what are the ammunition yep so missions
are various things if you look down the
left hand side that's you've got that I
can swear different weapons there oh
yeah
and got loads that's what gosh this'll
take too many hacks to get in anyway so
yeah too bad I could get in here which
is gosh that's yeah so you've got a
shotgun so that's not grammar that's
pretty good yeah you've got two left
- yeah so I'll take one to get from a
cockpit if you want to do that where as
an that also leads to so that door
pretty sure here yeah pretty sure you
need to get through there to get to oh
yeah both the cockpit and also if you
scroll like there's another all bobtails
got to for one there
hooray let's go kill some people I might
use my gun though okay I use the custom
pistol I just so own across the boat on
those it's very good so that see a
smaller radius it's not so much the
Roman guards that you have to worry
about it's all the sick seated guards
they all get up when you rise gonna
shoot the squad he died of head oh yeah
so you're safe there and then channel
them all in yeah well they actually
weren't here because it's you know just
outside the radius Oh
shotguns a quite powerful yeah I'm not
sure that was a dot that killed him
where him hitting his head off wall
afterwards so they also drop the weapon
when they die and if they okay that guy
did here now so he's coming from up see
what it's the right master slowing up
luckily he headed towards sound
negging your location nice so yeah see
see how far his rent you think when you
shot him
there's someone standing behind him the
wrench can knock out the guy behind and
prevent one of these discs what do you
think that oh that's a chef controls yes
you can fly the ship around sit there
you can also sit in the turret seat and
fire a missile and in fact sigh blow me
up
once you have done looting the place it
would be good to sit in the cockpit and
then any of these guys the Gunners you
just alive they don't know the ship's
been hijacked so if you rights if you
tell a ship to fire they will all fire
so that goes just a wrench guys so
that's about to say as long as you hold
the slow-mo key you should be fine like
all right get out of my ship I loved it
that's how to dispose of people it makes
sense cuz you can oh my dad's okay
that's my fault I died so much when I
was playing that you'd lost so much
blood that there was no no blood left
excellent but if you pick new life then
your next character will have
like a fresh stock of blood that's a
weird way to say you're just gonna be a
new person
yeah well that's isn't that how it works
it's if you so it moves our blood or it
might just be taking a really long time
sometimes a really long time starting
your life which is strange because it's
not actually generating in your galaxy
it's just kind of delete player great
player yeah for some reason some take
longer so do you think people are going
to what's the incentive I guess as a
player to keep playing with another part
do you think people are basically going
to try and take over the entire universe
on their own as one player I think the
sort of true roguelike experience
probably not I imagine that's gonna be
extremely difficult I'm also not
necessarily encouraging you to try and
dominate the whole galaxy as one faction
right like I say once you get this
faction to a certain degree of like
success once they have got enough
stations that they can survive that's
when you're unlocked the other factions
and I think if you are if you're playing
as The Foundry all this time and then
suddenly you get the opportunity to
players should go yeah then you'll try
it out right and you might like them
they might might have you know she grow
kind of ruthless cooperation here
assassinate people on a regular basis so
their shops are going to have stealthy
equipment near silenced weapons and
stuff or as Foundry a kind of engineers
and so they have better tech for your
ship there we a faction that is strictly
non-lethal will never I'll cool they'll
always want you to keep people alive and
they're like the law enforcement from
the nearest planet which is a long way
away so there's a variety in there which
you think players were going to like
warm - yeah so I hope you'll just kind
of mess around and try different
factions you'll probably like one more
than the others but variety is the key
and it's kind of that system is partly
inspired by there's a moral sorry Skyrim
mod where instead of playing as the
savior of the world who's a prisoner who
is you know destined to slay all the
dragons and be the Dragonborn hmm you
just spawn as a random NPC oh well a
barmaid in solitude or you might just be
a hunter or camping out in the in the
rift and I love the idea that each time
you play is just you just is a new
person each life is a new person
and when that person dies they're dead
forever and when you wow there's a new
character you're playing as a different
person
what was the big circle around the ship
when I first caught it was red
that's the he doesn't say what that was
it I'll kill them nice eat it we're
gonna take your ammunition while I'm
here what's this thing here that is the
heat sensor so we're over there and you
press e on it actually zoom out before
you press E and walk up a little bit and
then press E oh you just straight up
turn up
you can Sable it so it's not obviously
you already aboard so it doesn't help
you that much right now although if you
need to make it hasty escape that's very
useful because I didn't car didn't cop
on but the heat signatures is tied to
how much ya actually do it I thought you
were very intelligently keeping a thrust
below the threshold I didn't really well
it was kind of intuitive because I saw
that the it was cooling down as I was
getting to right so I was like oh I need
to slow down then I guess yeah accident
you know what actually no me I wonder I
really want to blow something up I don't
have any guns I can cheat and give you
one if you like oh please do and then
just pick a couple with stuff you get a
bypass tool or weapon and a jet pack
great one on one or you can shoot yeah
exactly
or idk fa yeah nicely yeah iddqd was the
other honours yeah that was
invincibility I think and I don't care
they what stamp something like ie V Keys
something [ __ ] every I mean they had
a BFG in the game so oh look at this i
ii almost a thruster yeah so that'll
make a ship accelerate faster hold on
make it more maneuverable doesn't mean
oh god oh god
alright last and now that guy's gonna
hear and it takes a long time for guns
to reload it does oh I'm so glad
what's that it's actually possible to
dodge bullets on ice in slow-mo because
they are slowing off suppress Abner and
chase the white arrow and this looked
like the hardest thing ever when you
because this is a real the bottom screen
is is
your blood leaving your body a turd
George Carlos nice that's really
satisfying
so eventually there'll be a kind of will
cut away the top of your ship and you'll
see inside as you land in your pilot's
seat you medical droid comes down and
seals over you and heals you up
excellent how far away do you think you
are from launch
do you even know it's it's you seem very
much like the I don't know it's like I
always find this when I talk to
especially individual developers like
you the process is so important right
like the actual yeah it's really an
exploration you're finding out what the
game could be and this this was going to
be a quick 10 minute action game where
every time you start your your ship is
blown up and this is just the escape pod
right easy escape pod to hunt down the
guy who Gloria [ __ ] once who did that if
the whole universe would reset and they
would just do it all again and it would
just be a kind of like I'm always
inspired by spelunking before everything
and write a quick 10 minute session of
spelunky is was what is everything you
going for and then after that was just
turned out to be really hard to build so
even though it was a short game I said
to build these systems for to have these
objects moving around the galaxy that
also work like levels of course you
module early destroyed and they split in
the right way and they have physics and
all the stuff you know you are when you
throw an item you are engaging in a
physics simulation which is aboard
another object another physics
simulation that's it's a complex game to
make and then I thought well it made the
basis for all the this whole world all
the stuff is flying around independently
and it can be vast why not make it an
actual open-world and why not give like
a strategy layer to your missions and
give you kind of you know actions that
you can influence the war between yeah
kind of evolved like rather organically
it seems little idea and so that kind of
long-term thing I mean depending on how
hard it is to make the game itself which
isn't finished yet these need I think
these ships need to be a lot more kind
of challenging and have not that I
didn't die but I want to be more about
little segments the ship where the doors
are all sealed off in your planning ok
how do I get past these three guys right
just standing there I
to plan ahead much like why you achieved
in gunpoint really yes so I mean that
part I'm sort of assuming I can do
haven't done it yet but like you say
that's kind of how gunpoint worked and
so hopefully I have some experience
there that can draw on all right I'm
gonna blow up this ship to finish our
stream here okay so like this or so
that's what's the best way you think to
so when you plant it it will destroy all
the nearby modules actually so would
that do all those or it might not be big
enough try yeah we're the cursor over
yourself for a space and that will drop
it and you cannot pick it back up again
okay so either thing to pay attention to
is there's that tiny little circle in
the middle yeah and any module that's
touching that at all will be destroyed
so it'll be the one you're standing in
the one below and so you could certainly
blow off like the back of a ship I could
give you more depth back to be like yeah
why not
I do the acuity although if we just
hammer you and pick up all that stuff
and then I can have a lot of custom
crystals careful not to throw the
pistols away too violently because if a
pistol hits a wall it will go off and
then just fires in a random direction
here at a great many other day way
through a shotgun at someone and it
happened to hit an owl first so all the
shells hit them at point-blank range and
it just flew across that really drop the
detonate I did how do I put them was
always good to like while standing the
blast radius we got jet pack I like I
literally have an intake of breath when
I did that a second of God you know
actually they can't go off maxint the
moment but that's what I should add yeah
and throw it hard enough at the wall see
how cool that be to rig a whole ship and
end up somebody 50% chance like a like a
roll to like if it lands on the big red
button on the desk and wreck
how do I put more of these guys there so
you need to switch them so you can press
Q to cycle through inventory and number
nine is a packed especially the spacebar
yeah and so spray fire throwers but if
the cursor is over you drop it alright
so yeah you know what good enough and
press 9 again to switch to another on
and then all over me so it's just there
and then once you're out of the blast
radius ever suggest like here right here
is that enough yeah that should be okay
double click to donate them all
double click left click double left I'm
just so terrified all right here we go
oh my oh okay I totally got sucked back
in you yeah that can happen actually if
you kind of you can ya fly at a one ship
and fly into another we had a guy who
got ejected from got kicked out of a
ship bleedin death and didn't remain
because I thought but then she was yeah
then just landed in another ship's
airlock just by chopper vastness of
space land and an airlock and I love
that because you have to imagine what
the cruiser reaction do that it's guys
bleeding to death he's unconscious
virtually and he's just slides injury
how do we get here puddle of blood
awesome
alright that's heat signatures thank you
so much Tom for coming in no worries
enough yeah see we're working out of two
years sometime in the next like the
future but how can people keep in
contact with its development cuz I know
you're very vocal about what you're
working on it's like I don't know you
you've a fascinating window into the
experience Thanks
yes I'm prettier from a development and
it's website I'm very excited to say is
spaceships cool really tough cool that's
this Europe that's you could guess see
are these one had spaceship scope really
man someone and NASA's like web team is
just like how dare he alright so
everything that spaceships are cool yep
go check it out and fear we're done here
from video games calm which is good URL
we have I guess yeah we need to give it
can we get video game star cool Tay can
we sort that out we can look for that
Idol thumbs up videos yeah problem yeah
somebody else's has gone in there
absolutely
Tom thanks very much coming in
appreciate your time yeah check out
spaceships are cool and for more a
wonderful live streams and a demos make
sure you stay tuned against Balcom here
subscribe on Twitch or hit follow on
Twitch rather and make sure you join us
at GameSpot calm as well I will see you
next time thanks to Erte for work in
production in the back and we're out
here adios